hello everyone is Silesia Malone from
Fandango and I am in Austria at a train
station right now
just taking a break from riding the
Bennis simplon Orient Express I got to
speak with Josh GAD who is one of the
stars of Murder on the Orient Express
and course this train was made famous by
Agatha Christie's novel now we have a
new movie coming which also stars Johnny
Depp's Michelle Pfeiffer Daisy Ridley
Kenneth Branagh who is also the director
in the film
I'm a cute sucker for a movie set on
train because not only is it super
glamorous but very claustrophobic as
well very much what do you think that
adds to the story I mean obviously the
story is on the ironing press but why is
it so great to see films that I train
you know it's just a position between
these incredible vistas against the
backdrop of this intimacy and people who
are stuck in clothes orders
yeah with secrets and I think that that
lends itself to not only great
storytelling but ultimately great
filming Murder on the Orient Express is
something that I think keeps being
revisited over and over again not only
because of the romanticism of that
period of the train itself but also
because the characters are so so well
detailed yeah
it must feel like such a treat when it
is a story that's so focused on story
this was one of those movies that be I
how could you not say yes and you have
this amazing Agatha Christie adaptation
with one of the great directors alive
and also one of the craziest Catholics
and when you have the director Kenneth
Branagh I mean everyone must want to
rise to his level I mean not only
director but horribly producer okay you
know co-writer kind of you know all of
it like he does he brings
such unbelievable commitment to every
job that he has and he was doing
pre-production on this movie as he was
performing on the West End
who's crazy crazy well thank you for
joining with me on the venison blonde
our eyes expressed in fun some reason no
matter yet not yes
[Music]
you